I have found the second person that
makes an incredible argument and he's
happens to be sitting here with me so
thanks so much for coming to New York
and doing this thanks mom appreciate you
having me are you ready I'm ready now
before we get started and getting to
your background there are a few people
who come in here prepared there is
nobody who has ever come in here with
what do you guys got 28 pages of notes
and as I read this I think I learned
more than I've heard in the last six
months so we got a lot to get through
what did you do before Bitcoin so I was
an accountant by trade I actually have
my master's degree in accounting and
Finance I spent four years as a
certified public accountant I then
branched out on the entrepreneurial path
as a CFO for a number of early-stage
companies a few tech companies okay and
then I actually began investing in
crypto personally in 2014 but more
heavily in 16 and actually didn't
realize what bitcoin was when I first
saw it and was drawn in more so by
etherium and the concept of smart
contracts and so I started making heavy
investments into the space late 16 or li
17 where my money went my mind followed
and then as I studied the space more and
more closely I became more and more of a
Bitcoin maximalist or rationalist and
what was the thing that pulled you in
with a theory my first of what caught
your eye you know it was the the
lightbulb moment was the realization
that the entire finance industry is a
smart contract with human beings on top
of it and a lot of strip stands to be
automated I think going forward all
right let's get into kind of this
ultimate argument for Bitcoin because I
think the way that you think through the
asset you come at it from a very first
principles based thought process right
and one of those first ideas is like
what is trade and how we think of unit
of account so maybe let's start there
and we kind of work our way into like
why Bitcoin actually matters perfect
so yeah I think it's easiest to start
from the beginning and the realization
that everything we say do or make starts
out as an idea like literally everything
we touch thinking about is an idea
before it's anything right and the
purpose of the world economy is to
generate and share useful ideas through
trade as we trade our ideas become
better giving everything we say do or
make more specialized qualities an easy
way to think about this is considering
how like our transportation technologies
have gone from wagons to automobiles to
airplanes for sure dad
and so in trade everything is valued at
summary - of everything else
meaning that you know this car might be
worth 132 chairs or this house might be
worth 11 cars and money is the medium
through which we more easily calculate
these exchange ratios it's basically a
base unit or a common unit of account
that we can always go back into 'but
when we go to trade absolutely like a
universal measurement system yeah the
second or the meter or anything else
right so like any other tool the purpose
of money is to save as time and
generating time savings itself is the
purpose of all tools so for instance we
can dig more holes per hour using a
shovel then we can with our bare hands
and in this sense money is just a tool
that helps us negotiate and execute
trades more quickly so it's a medium
through which economic actors
communicate their preferences which
drives human action and what this means
is it like by choosing to buy a car or
sell your house the economy responds
dynamically by producing more cars and
less houses essentially so contrary to
popular misconception money is not a
government creation which I think most
people are under that illusion okay
you're going to explain that one
absolutely and so the simplest way to
think about this is that money arises
naturally in any trading society it is
simply the most tradable thing so as
people seek to satisfy their wants
through trade they steadily seek to
trade their things for more tradable
things to get closer to the thing they
ultimately want
so as this dynamic unfolds something
necessarily becomes most tradable or
more treatable than everything else
whether it's salt cattle or gold and
this most exchangeable thing is money as
societies advance historically they
coalesced around precious metals as
money due to their superior monetary
traits of durability divisibility
portability recognizability
and most importantly scarcity so gold
which is the most scarce monetary metal
came to dominate the world as its supply
is the most inflation resistant or
inelastic governments co-opted gold and
over time they built a pyramid scheme on
top of gold called fiat currency all
right so let's stop for a second here
where when you talk about these five
superior monetary traits durability
divisibility portability recognized
ability and scarcity just give us a
quick one second on each one of those
what are those actually me absolutely so
durability means it is it persists
across time so you know it won't
physically deteriorate which metal is
really good at the visibility means it
can be broken down and recombined into
various amounts so you can easily
calculate and trade things also which
gold is good at and form of coins
portability means it can be transported
across space so you're moving value
across space recognizability means it
can be assayed or verified by someone
that's trading so you can actually tell
that it's actually gold or or cash and
then scarcity is just limited supply
which maybe is not you yes
so scarcities of primary importance
because anyone that can compromise that
supply will do so to steal the value
stored therein so which we do with fiat
currency today for sure and so when you
say that gold was co-opted by
governments what does that mean so when
I say it's co-opted and I call fiat
currency a pyramid scheme it'll help to
define a pyramid scheme so a pyramid
scheme is essentially a business
structure in which those in higher tiers
still value from those in lower tiers so
fiat currency is a pyramid scheme with
central bank's at the top who hold the
only real money today which is gold that
generate profits by making loans
two successive layers of banks below
them with each layer profiting from the
loans it makes to the subsequent layers
of banks below them so the people at the
top make the most the people under them
make the second most the people under
the third-most etc yeah and the people
using the currency at the bottom of the
scheme get stuck holding the bag so to
speak and those are the everyday
citizens in the bottom 50% everyone
using fiat currency exactly so it's a
leverage based business that requires
steadily more debt accumulation to
remain functional over time and it
inevitably breaks down when the debt
load becomes unserviceable which I would
argue is happening in the world today so
when governments commandeered the market
for money
it became unfree or centrally planned so
we moved away from a free market which
we call capitalism to a centrally
planned market which is something more
akin to socialism so in this sense you
know free markets are natural organizing
principles that encourage us to find
better ways of doing things by making
bets with one another so as we can prove
others wrong in the marketplace by
finding and selling better ways of doing
things the productivity gains diffused
into society through trade these gains
come in the form of better ways of
saying doing and making things set
differently productivity gains come from
more specialized ideas which come from
trade so in this sense free markets are
idea meritocracies which we're going to
talk more about here in a minute free
markets are essentially unhampered trade
networks that encourage the cultivation
and diffusion of the best ideas within
society all regulations and limitations
on free market dynamics reduce their
efficacy the ultimate expression of
regulation is a monopoly in which the
free market in which all free market
competition is suppressed through
coercion or violence and in the world
today the market for money is not a free
market that is forcibly dominated by
banking cartels and these are two things
here right the first the free market
dynamics is literally laws that prevent
people from creating other fiat
currencies except and then the banking
cartels kind of an air quotes is both
the government banking or so
Federal Reserve central banks but also
the financial organizations as well to
have some hand in kind of how all this
works absolutely I think to put it
kindly they're all in bed together and
the the the defining characteristic
would be that they do not allow free
market experimentation to compete with
fiat currency so the market is unable to
adapt or learn or evolve at all because
it's centrally planned and controlled
okay so in that sense fiat currency
pyramid schemes are monopolies which as
we learned in economics 101 come at a
very heavy cost to society monopolies
increased prices they decrease
innovation and they've reduced trade so
where as free markets make mankind
become more productive which is an
economic benefit monopolies or unfree
markets make mankind become less
productive which is anti economic so
with all this sort of background in mind
on money and markets we are here today
to talk about one of the greatest
capitalists in history mr. Ray Dalio
all right before we get into Dalia one
of the things that you and I have
connected on and I think really kind of
drove us to want to do this was Ray has
written a number of really great pieces
that basically highlights the entire
Bitcoin argument - the conclusion of
Bitcoin is the answer yes a lot of probe
Bitcoin pieces without ever saying but
so let's start with Ray and then we'll
kind of get into the arguments etc but
but just so for people at home that's
essentially one of the main reasons why
we wanted to do this yes because she's
right there on the edge he he's there
and he's you know he's long gold which
if you understand gold and you really
understand the valuation fundamentals
then you should understand Bitcoin and
its valuation fundamentals there shortly
so ray is the most successful hedge fund
manager in history and that's that's not
hyperbole that's fact he started
Bridgewater his firm from his apartment
which today is valued at I think about a
hundred and sixty billion dollars he
incepted a cultural paradigm at his
hedge fund called the idea meritocracy
in the idea meritocratic culture candid
reviews of colleagues are encouraged so
in his book he wrote a book called
principles he even shares a memo that a
subordinate shared with the entire firm
at Bridgewater grading ray addy for his
performance at a meeting so the idea is
that everyone can review everyone
candidly you know even up to and
including the CEO so this cultural style
promotes the propagation of truth and
minimizes office politics and in this
spirit I decided to write an open letter
to read a Leo regarding Bitcoin to
review his assessment of Bitcoin so I
started this essay by giving ray and f4
his assessment of Bitcoin for three
reasons and he laid out basically three
critiques of Bitcoin and I went through
them in turn
so first ray says that he is sold on
blockchain technology but not Bitcoin
despite Bitcoin being the only market
proven use case today for blockchain I
argue that blockchain today is a mostly
unproven buzzword you know there are
some potential use cases for it perhaps
but none of them are market proven or as
Bitcoin is more it is being market
proven in real time and it is the
hardest monetary technology in history
so I don't think you can be long
blockchain and short Bitcoin it just
makes no sense it's kind of like saying
hey I like the Internet but the largest
Internet company I'm not into that one
Hanabusa yeah I like the internet but
not HTTP here so I don't know some
analogy like that but so that was the
first critique secondly and this one's a
bit longer but I think this is really
important and a lot of people struggle
to get this one ray says that bitcoin
could be disrupted by another
cryptocurrency
citing iPhone disrupting blackberry as a
comparative example now this is
extremely unlikely because bitcoin is a
path dependent one-time invention it's
critical breakthrough is the discovery
of absolute scarcity a monetary property
property never before and never again
achievable by mankind that's a mouthful
so this is probably one of the most
important thing
those that either are just learning
about Bitcoin or are trying to
understand why bitcoin is different than
everything else so really explain what
exactly you mean here absolutely so for
instance with path dependence we'll
start with that path dependence entails
that the sequence of events matters as
much as the events themselves for
instance you get a dramatically
different result if you shower then dry
yourself off versus if you dry yourself
off and then shower pretty clear example
yeah pretty clear right so as a thought
experiment if a new Bitcoin was launched
today it would have extremely weak chain
security early on as its minor network
in hash Street would have to develop
from scratch and today in a world where
awareness of Bitcoin is more prevalent
this new Bitcoin with comparatively weak
chain security would inevitably be
attacked by incumbents whether these
were incumbent projects seeking to
defend their head start international
banking cartels or even nation-states
path dependence protects Bitcoin from
disruption as the organic sequence of
events which led to its release and
assimilation into the market place
cannot be replicated further bitcoins
money supply has absolutely scarce a
totally unique and one-time discovery
from money consider that if this new
Bitcoin was released with an absolutely
scarce money supply that its holders
would be incentivized to hold the money
with the greatest liquidity Network
effects and chain security this would
cause them to dump new Bitcoin for the
original even if this new Bitcoin
featured a diminishing money supply so
negative scarcity if you will or in
other words a deflationary monetary
policy how would its rate and mechanism
of money supply decay be determined as
market participants jockey for position
to maximize their economic benefit of
the deflation deflationary monetary
policy chain forks would ensue that
would diminish the liquidity and chain
security for new Bitcoin causing
everyone to eventually pile back into
original Bitcoin
so essentially bitcoins terminal money
supply growth rate of absolute zero is
the ultimate monetary selling point
and shelling point is a game theoretic
focal point that people tend to choose
by default in an adversarial game like
money all right so the ultimate monetary
shelling point and the terminal money
supply growth rate of absolute zero
first let's start with the terminal
money supply growth rate what is that
absolutely so bitcoin is issued on a
perfectly predictable supply curve that
terminates in the mid 22nd century
so no more Bitcoin will ever be issued
into existence after that and this is
the thought process of starts at 50
Bitcoin every block word you get cut in
half to 25 there open 1/2 6.5 you go all
the way down and eventually you
literally can't split in half anymore
absolutely and it goes to 0 is basically
exponential decay that approaches zero
so I think today before the may having
were like 1800 Bitcoin produced per day
to give you an idea how quickly this
contracts by the year 2100 I think we're
below 1 the Senate tweet about that but
it just contracts very quickly so
mankind you know our biggest weakness is
our inability to understand exponential
growth or decay so this is it's a really
big deal ok so back to game theory and
the selling point piece in game theory a
game is just any situation where they
can be winners or losers a strategy is
just a decision-making process and a
shelling point is the default strategy
for games and which players cannot fully
trust one another like money so the
absolute scarcity of Bitcoin in this
sense is a really big deal and I like to
compare it to the discovery actually of
the number zero the discovery of zero
was special as it represents absolute
nothingness its role as a placeholder
gives our numerical system its power to
scale and cycle through other numbers
giving them different meanings depending
on its location consider the difference
between twenty and twenty million each
zero represents another order of
magnitude of the integer to
similarly the discovery of absolute
scarce money is special gold became
money because of the monetary metals it
had the most inelastic or relatively
scarce money supply this meant that no
matter how much time was allocated
towards gold production its supply
increased the least meaning that no
matter how hard or how many resources
people threw at and to get more gold it
was still the hardest to get exactly so
it's kind of like this game theoretic
backstop and that's what makes it become
money and that's why people express
things in that value because it's the
most predictable supply okay keep going
with golden in bold compared to Bitcoin
absolutely so since its supply increased
the most slowly and predictably gold was
favored for pricing things and became
the dominant money on the free market
the absolute scarcity of Bitcoin makes
it the ultimate pricing mechanism for
the ceaseless changes in human
productivity enabling societies to more
effectively communicate their
preferences through trade store their
wealth securely and cooperate and
compete at scale so when it comes to
gold there's two components that you
just described one is the difficulty at
which to produce it the second is the
predictability of the incoming supply
right or the new supply yep both of
those things are pretty proven over
thousands of years it's really hard to
make or or get and we've got a pretty
good idea of how much we're digging up
out of the ground every year finding etc
when it comes to Bitcoin it is harder to
get Bitcoin than it is to get gold in
terms of the production and also it is
verifiably true what that supply is at
all times with an incredible amount of
accuracy absolutely which is basically
taking all of the properties of gold
that we have put value on and now
putting them in a much more scientific
provable provable mathematic type
mentality or mechanism and so it's
actually improving on those mechanisms
of gold or aspects of gold for bit
that's exactly correct and so if you
think if we could somehow miraculously
press pause on everyone's job today
until everyone to go mined gold we could
produce a lot more gold right we get a
lot more above-ground a lot more quickly
you could not do that with Bitcoin
Bitcoin has this ingenious invention
called the difficulty adjustment that's
basically like an ever receding horizon
the more you chase it the further it
runs away so we know with essentially
perfect mathematical certainty exactly
how many Bitcoin will be issued between
now and the last Bitcoin being mined in
the mid 22nd century again that's a
property we've never had with any asset
commodity or whatsoever and I think the
part that is really important in that is
this difficulty adjusting adjustment
works both directions so if we put more
resources towards mining right if you
and I are partners and we want to
produce Bitcoin know the more that we
put overall it becomes harder for
everyone on the network to get their
share that they previously had because
of that difficulty adjustment that's
growing but also if we shut down our
operations it can get easier as well and
so the ability to increase or decrease a
difficulty based on the production
investment mm-hmm we've just never seen
that before
no never seen it it's like dynamic
demand adjustment and you know with gold
the the marginal revenue or the market
price tends to converge with the
marginal cost of production so as we see
kind of Bitcoin hash rate growing which
is how much operational and capital
expenditure is being allocated towards
its production we can use that as a
proxy for what we think the value will
go so I think the hash rate today is 13
times what it was at the December 2017
peak so that's kind of we look at it
it's kind of a leading indicator and
that positive feedback loop that is a
Bitcoin for sure so let's go back to the
number zero absolutely so in the same
way that the number zero enables our
numeric system to scale and more easily
perform calculation so to does money
give an economy and ability to socially
scale and more easily perform economic
calculation
and social scalability is one of those
terms from Nick Szabo that essentially
means the more we can do with less
effort or without thinking about it the
more productive we are as a society so
back to money simply scarcity is
essential to the utility of money and a
zero growth terminal money supply
represents perfect scarcity which makes
Bitcoin a perfect monetary technology
from this perspective both the discovery
of zero and absolute scarcity our ideas
or tools that enable society to scale by
saving us time and calculation and trade
so that was a long run so I'll try to
summarize it a little bit since the
invention of Bitcoin represents the
discovery of absolute scarcity or
absolute ear reproducibility which
occurred due due to a particular
sequence of idiosyncratic events its
emergence into the world cannot itself
be reproduced absolute scarcity is a
one-time discovery just like the
heliocentric model of the solar system
or any other major scientific paradigm
shift alright so there's a lot of people
who do not believe in Bitcoin or do not
see the value and what they would
basically say is there's a lot of big
words but you made a claim that absolute
scarcity is a one-time discovery can it
be replicated but it's just the first
time it's discovered there's value or is
it absolute scarcity can only happen one
time I think as a monetary property it
can only be discovered once because
money is valued based on its liquidity
and network effects so if you try to
reproduce Bitcoin 2.0 with absolute
scarcity today the value of that just
gets collapsed in a Bitcoin because it
already has such a huge lead in terms of
liquidity and network effects and I
don't see how you can disrupt that okay
a fair launch yeah so in short like a
fair launch via a proof-of-work system
is no longer possible due to path
dependence yet another reason when
cannot be replicated or disrupted by
another crypto asset using this
consensus mechanism so at this point it
seems
absolute scarcity for money is truly a
one-time discovery that cannot be
disrupted any more than the number zero
can be disrupted a true Bitcoin killer
would necessitate an entirely new
consensus and distribution model and
nothing to date has been conceived that
could fulfill this requirement so in the
same way that there's only ever been one
analog gold it looks like there's only
ever gonna be one digital gold so that
was a long katika phrase second critique
so part of this is the properties that
make gold valuable have been
supercharged or put on steroids when it
comes to Bitcoin they're more provable
they're more mathematically factual if
you will and the argument you're making
is that although we can identify what
those properties are and we can assign
value to them they cannot be replicated
for a variety of different reasons and
some of that is the actual feature
itself cannot be replicated and then
some of it is the features position in a
sequential list or of events cannot be
replicated you know depending on either
one of those when you combine them you
cannot reproduce Bitcoin in the form
that it is and kind of the value that it
is yeah yeah I guess since it's a game
theoretic you can't replay the game so
to speak of money right you can't just
no one can decree gold is no longer
valuable the free market determines that
it has value the free market has
determined that Bitcoin has value and
these as money you know the more
liquidity more network effects it has
the more value it has so they call us to
a single money so that's what we have
one gold and for all all indications
today our point is the one digital gold
so to speak okay third third point that
Ray had yeah so Ray's third critique of
Bitcoin is he says that price stable
central bank or corporate issued crypto
currencies like Libre or a better
alternative than Bitcoin as it is too
unstable to be used as a medium of
exchange
so in one sense it's true because
central banks are already announcing
their attempts at this however the one
thing they will never do is give up
control of monetary policy which means
that this is the means by the monetary
policy control through which they enrich
themselves and this goes by a lot of
names
the Cantillon effect confiscation via
inflation the shadow tax or even
taxation without representation
so since bitcoin has an absolutely
scarce money supply which is a monetary
policy akin to absolute zero it will
continue to appreciate on an exchange
ratio basis against fiat currencies
which are inevitably printed into
worthlessness over time exchange ratio
of volatility against fiat currency is a
normal consequence of price discovery
for an emergent asset like Bitcoin so a
good kind of example for this is to
consider Amazon which crashed 94 percent
from eighty five dollars to five dollars
in 1999 before growing over 33,000
percent since and its ascent to market
dominance today and Amazon accomplished
this historic feat by gaining control of
the digital market for distribution
networks this the space which Amazon
conquered is driven by scarcity in the
form of finite distribution channels and
it is subject to winner-take-all
dynamics due to network effects and
economies of scale
similarly the market for money is driven
by scarcity and subject to
winner-take-all dynamics as we saw with
gold
so in fact bitcoin is monetizing along
the same path as gold today and that
it's being used first as a store value
then once it has accrued enough value to
incentivize people to spend it it will
become more widely adopted as a medium
of exchange and when it finally is used
widely enough it will become the primary
denominator of prices worldwide making
it a unit of account so this is like the
same evolutionary path that gold
followed we see Bitcoin following today
ok so there's there's two pieces here
that I want to cover
so first is Amazon you describe this 94%
drawdown that it has
also many people don't know that every
single year since it's been public it's
drawn down double-digit percentage at
least once and I think the average intra
a year drawdown is like over 30 percent
yeah right right and so when you start
to look at it it's just that all equates
to it's a highly volatile stock this but
volatility works both ways
you need volatility to go up you also
need volatility to go down and so if
you're going to have the best performing
stock or stock that goes from
non-existent to the dominant one in the
world you have to have that volatility
right but nothing's gonna go from zero
to hero if you will without actually
having the volatility in between of
course you know the world is dominated
by nonlinearities and when you're
looking at a binary bit like Amazon that
was either bust or you know the original
just online bookstore we didn't see that
it was gonna evolve and all this but
it's it dominated that space right and
Bitcoin sort of the same it's like it's
either worth nothing or it's a global
reserve asset so this volatility is the
market trying to discover what it is is
it zero or is it here oh so speak for
sure and then the second thing you talk
here about is this idea that bitcoins
monetizing along the same path that's
gold so gold essentially nobody used
then people started to use it as hey
this is valuable do you want to actually
barter or use it then it became a more
valuable asset over time as more and
more people say hey well I want some of
that and then at some point once it had
this quote-unquote stable value right
because people knew this is what it is
worth people then started to use it as
an actual currency and then eventually
prices of the assets people sort of say
hey well I will trade you Mike you know
my camel for two gold coins absolutely
bitcoins do the same thing absolutely
and we think you know our unit of
account today's dollars largely dollars
used to be gold right dollars were deema
before gold so he proclaim on gold yeah
we were thinking in gold even though we
we think we're thinking in dollars today
which are no longer pegged to gold which
we'll get to we were actually thinking
in gold for that very reason so that
that was that covers like my three
responses to raise three critiques
of his assessment of Bitcoin then after
reading his book principles I realized
that Bitcoin positively embodied many of
the principles Rey lays out in his book
so I decided to write my essay which is
titled an open letter to Ray Dalio
regarding Bitcoin to share my findings
which brings us to the first principle
alright so you saw it ray said you
responded to Ray then you read the book
he said wait a minute it's even more of
a reason why he should actually be
paying attention to this yes and you
wrote about kind of breaking down
Bitcoin in the framework of the
principles in which he is sharing with
the world
absolutely so his explaining it to him
through his own worldview if you will
all right let's start with the first
principle which is this idea of
meritocracy yes so the pinnacle of Ray's
worldview is the idea meritocracy which
Ray describes as quote idea meritocratic
decision-making is better than
traditional autocratic or democratic
decision-making in almost all cases so
an idea meritocracy is a cultural
paradigm it's a free market for ideas a
way of subjecting ideas to a simulated
form of natural selection it's a kind of
Darwinism for ideas if you will and I
see is an open environment for the
proliferation and combination of the
most meritorious ideas free from
man-made impediments such as ego policy
and hierarchy so again team member team
members at Bridgewater review one
another's work meeting contributions and
attitude in real time using a suite of
custom-made management tools which are
software based tools used to gather
real-time feedback an idea meritocracy
is intended to be aligned with reason
and impervious to politics it's kind of
the gist of it and you know I think we
see this in the world that the more
objectively measurable and traceable the
outcome of a job the less political it
is by nature as competence is the
primary determinant of who gets that job
so an example here would be like
consider how professional athletes are
paid for points they put on the board or
other stats which are objective metrics
whereas a politician is paid based on
his charisma or cunning which is clearly
very subjective
so you know jumping back to our original
thesis that everything starts out as an
idea since everything we say do or make
starts out as an idea the idea
meritocracy is a free market it's the
same thing
and this is really you know people who
work in like a corporate job will
understand this really well is if I have
an idea the actual idea by itself
doesn't matter who brought it up when
they brought it up and how they brought
it up I mean it's just the idea the
actual merits of the idea the best ideas
can withstand attacks from every
direction salute they can withstand the
attack of who brought it up why how
where everything what we tend to see in
organizations or and even larger in the
world is not idea meritocracies we tend
to see hierarchies and we tend to see
the I'm the boss it's my idea to do it
my way even if it's not the best idea
and so I think that the technology world
has done much better job of kind of
encouraging some of these meritocracies
and some of that is because to your
point you know when I was at Facebook
one of the phrases that they would use
is code wins arguments hmm we can sit
here all day long and debate things no
like let's go build it it works or it
doesn't
huh that's right and so that was a form
of a meritocracy in the sense of like if
you build it and it works then like what
are we arguing about like it works right
and so I think that's what we're seeing
kind of a very big division in the world
of the people who previously weren't
exposed to nor wanted idea meritocracies
are doubling and tripling down on the
prevention of them absolutely the people
who like this world and and believe in
the value of the idea of meritocracies
they're doing everything they possibly
can to double and triple down on the
protection of them yeah and so you get
this very diverse of diverse world or
division in the world but it comes back
to the idea of either you by ideas have
merit on their own or they don't know or
you buy into who says it when where how
et cetera is almost more important than
the ideas of which people share
absolutely you know I think that the
division you speak of is sort of between
dominance and
competence right where dominance being
it goes because I said so because my
desk is bigger than yours whereas
competence is like this thing works in
the real world and according to the
market test or it doesn't right and I
think if you just think about that it's
clear which of the two outcompetes the
other right of course this the the
domination thing is just not sustainable
like people that are dominated are
resentful right they're gonna always
find a way to kind of stab you on the
back or not work as hard or whatever
whereas competence hierarchies if you
will reward ingenuity and and innovation
things of that sort so I I agree I think
the world is going going that way so
getting back to kind of what markets are
in that respect markets are necessary to
disseminate knowledge because knowledge
has a localized dimension to it meaning
every person is most familiar with the
prevailing economic circumstances
specific to their place and space-time
and Industry free markets are the best
assimilators and disseminators of these
localized pools of knowledge within an
economy and a free market can be thought
of in this sense as it kind of Nexus
where many minds become one through the
mechanism of price and that's
you
and in this sense free-market capitalism
is directed by the collective decisions
of all economic actors where essentially
planned socialism is directed by the
decisions of a handful of bureaucrats
kind of what we're talking about here so
you know free markets reward comp plan
markets or reward dominance effectively
and in that sense socialism is a
top-down unnatural despotic organization
and you can kind of think of the
traditional org chart as you brought up
whereas capitalism is bottom-up natural
democratic which is much more like the
idea meritocratic organization that Ray
founded and one thing just to comment
here because I've been fortunate of to
spend enough time 3d type world and also
this Silicon Valley technology world
many of the largest organizations in the
world today from the technology sector
although they appear from the external
to be very top-down kind of traditional
org charts and when you get inside of
them they are incredible meritocracy
right there are much more flat
organizations than you would
traditionally see in large organizations
and so I think that outside of something
like you know Bitcoin versus a gold
versus fiat currencies etc we see other
applications of this in our world today
and the people who are winning in those
competitions there are the people who
tend to have much more meritocracies in
their organization absolutely and
therefore it would be natural for us to
see that seep into other aspects of our
lives and continue to be the superior
way or disappear frankly that's why I I
agree completely and I guess sort of the
backdrop to that is you know digital
technology enables us to exchange things
so much more fluidly that it just it
dissolves these dominance hierarchies
and rewards competence again and another
like ray is a big fan of Steve Jobs
and I remember Steve Jobs I'm coming
paraphrasing but he said an apple we
don't have committees or bored me like
we just figure out the best way to do
things and that's why we're the best
that's a shocking strategy yeah
so alright the elephant in the room yeah
so the elephant in the room then is why
in light of the overwhelming evidence
favoring a free-market economic system
do we still tolerate central planning in
the largest market of all the market
from money so to understand the
differences in free and unfree markets a
set of formulas will help us go a little
further and Ray gives us the following
formula for the idea meritocracy which
equals radical truth plus radical
transparency plus believability weighted
decision-making so the the formula that
he uses is radical truth added to
radical transparency added to
believability weighted decision-making
equals this idea of meritocracy yes this
three inputs yes radical truth radical
transparency and believability weighted
decision-making yes and again since idea
meritocracies are free and free markets
are the same thing we can translate this
to a free markets version if you will
and this is my sort of translation so I
say free markets equal truthful price
signals which we're going to talk more
about here in a second plus transparent
and reliable rule of law private
property rights in heart
plus skin in the game weighted
decision-making okay so your three
inputs are truthful price signals
transparent and reliable rule of law
private property rights and hard money
and then the third is skin in the game
weighted decision making that's exactly
right okay and there's a lot of terms in
there you may not be familiar with but
we will go into them let's go
so with these formulas in mind let's
dive into each of their elements and
consider their relationships with
markets money and Bitcoin the first
formulaic element of Ray's idea
meritocracy is the principle of radical
truth which ray describes as quote truth
or more precisely an accurate
understanding of reality is the
essential foundation for any good
outcome unquote I love that it's great
right like forget Bitcoin forget
anything just truth or more precisely an
accurate understanding of reality is the
essential foundation for any good
outcome when you sit and think about
that duh right well just like if you
don't have an accurate understanding of
reality how the hell can you do anything
to make decisions you know evaluates to
none that stuff so of course it is true
but the fact that he has to clearly
state it yeah to kind of put that in
people's minds is actually a little
scary in the world yeah I agree it's
funny it's like we're constantly trying
to redraw our map of reality and if
you're not paying attention to the
redrawing process reality is gonna run
you over
right absolutely all right so this is
his principle of radical truth yes so
this is the idea that gaining a clear
perception of reality is paramount to
facing it head-on and dealing with it so
in markets it's commonly said that price
is truth meaning that all known market
realities are expressed in any
particular assets price at any given
moment you may remember from economics
101 that the market price is the
intersection of supply which is an
objective quality and demand which is an
inner subjective or opinion based
quality so put another way prices are
like data packets that convey
information about scarce
city which is objective and value which
is inter subjective each entrepreneurs
decision to buy or sell is influenced by
prevailing prices an intern communicates
back into the market the state of
economic conditions relevant to him
which again in turn influences the same
decision-making of all other
entrepreneurs within his market that
this is inter subjective value and all
of those decisions are based on actual
availability of time resources and
know-how this is objective scarcity so
really what you're describing here is
the most important concept when it comes
to Bitcoin supply and demand and that
supply and demand leads to all sorts of
things like price discovery etc but
understanding fundamentally what is
supply and demand if you don't have that
belief that understanding etc you're
gonna really struggle to understand
Bitcoin absolutely so again back to
truth which is price it exists at the
intersection between objective reality
and our subjective interpretations of it
essentially and the objective reality
for example when it comes to Bitcoin is
1800 Bitcoin are gonna get created today
you're out of the 21 million that will
ever be available that's correct
that is provable with math no one can
deny that yes the subjective element is
how many people want those 21 million
bitcoins that's right and that's where
when those two things intersect kind of
truth versus perceived truth that's
where you get price discovery yes and
they feed back into one another right so
after the may twenty twenty having in a
couple of months it's going to constrict
by half to nine hundred Bitcoin per day
and you know the Bitcoin feedback loop
theory at least is it as you can
constrict scarcity and money it actually
drives demand for that money in addition
to the other benefits Bitcoin provides
like inflation resistance confiscation
resistance etc so getting back the price
signals price basically representing
truth in the marketplace central bank's
broke the truthfulness of money by
centralizing gold and issuing depository
receipts which are basically dollars
that were redeemable for gold in excess
of their gold reserves
so if they had ten tons of gold they
issued a hundred tons worth of dollars
redeemable for gold so they're just
making promises in excess of what they
had and the thought process here was if
I give out ten times the number of IOUs
to what I actually have mathematically
I'm going to take the risk that not
everyone is going to come ask me for the
gold at the same time that's exactly
right
which 99.9% of the time isn't was true
no there have been very specific cases
though these clinical bank runs where
people panic and they say whoa timeout I
want my gold right you ever seen what is
the the viral video another viral video
from Mobile Alabama where they said
leprechauns are in the tree oh man a lot
to play one day but there's basically
these guys and there's a folklore in the
neighborhood that there's a leprechaun
and it cuts away at the end to a guy he
goes I want the gold where to go that
I'll get me a backhoe and dig up that
tree I want my gold and so it's
somewhere here right it was I want my
gold but if you've promised more io
u--'s than you have you obviously can't
pay everybody absolutely that's the
truth that's the breaking of the
truthfulness is you just got yes and
when the trust breaks down things go
more free-market again right people want
the gold they don't want your promises
they want hard money so we gotta we
gotta get that clip man I want to go
where to go that high so when central
banks did this they severed the skin in
the game of money and gave central
bank's a mechanism for perpetually
privatizing profits from money
production which is called senior edge
and socializing government losses
through inflation so skin in the game
it's a really important concept for my
favorite author
Nassim Nicholas Taleb and that guy's was
he's if you haven't read his books he's
unbelievable read them all twice I draw
in his wisdom a lot am i thinking about
writing but so skin in the game is a
concept based on symmetry it's a balance
of incentives and disincentives that is
necessary for most systems to function
darling so with central banking it has
essentially no disincentives in the fiat
currency system as there is a near zero
cost of money production central bankers
are incentivized to print money into
worthlessness acquiring scarce assets
with these self annihilating currencies
on their gradual than sudden way to zero
so again if you go back to gold that the
marginal costs of production
tends to converge with its market price
the marginal cost of production of fiat
currency is zero for all intents and
purposes it's know like it's intuitive
where the values end up they converge to
zero because of market dynamics and
important to this point which I don't
hear talked a lot about is there is a
convergence of two components one is
theoretical and one is reality or a
historical reality the theoretical is
what you just described well if it costs
zero to produce and how could it have
value right and kind of you can pull a
lot of intellectual Olympics to unpack
what that exactly means but we also know
that every fiat currency in the world
historically and also every currency
other than the modern-day currencies
that have been created at we're still
living in their kind of average life
cycles have all failed because of
debasement or the devaluing of these
currencies because ultimately no matter
how valuable it starts if you devalue or
debase it away over time will you trend
toward zero yes right and then there's
all kinds of implications of that but we
just we have the theoretical frameworks
of which simple things like supply and
demand etc all apply and as long as we
believe Eilidh concepts there's a
theoretical argument but we also have
the historical track record and the
failures of that model of inflationary
or devaluing of a currency that just
leads to zero at some point absolutely
and it's the best we've ever had like
it's the best of the worst ideas yes and
fiat currency is not a new thing like
started I think 7th century China was
the first one every one of them have
ended
hyperinflation this is not like it
happens sometimes every time it happens
and the only you know the
best-performing one today is the British
Pound 317 years old it's lost ninety
nine and a half percent of its value
right and as you said we're living - its
kind of normal life cycle they all trend
towards zero it's just it's an empirical
fact so in this sense as a wise man once
said inflation is the surest way to
fertilize the rich man's filled with the
sweat of the poor man's brow ow yeah I
never heard that one before inflation is
the surest way to fertilize the rich
man's filled with the sweat of the poor
man's brow yeah essentially saying the
rich get richer the poor get poorer yeah
and they're doing it by backstabbing
them right you're surreptitiously taxing
them by printing more money and people
not understanding how the system works
just think the whole prices go up every
year and that's just the natural way of
things and it's really kind of insidious
in that sense so inflation the money
supply and this is very important for
capitalism it's a violation of private
property rights as it reallocates wealth
away from the its original owners who
are the citizens into the hands of those
closest to the governors of the monetary
system who are typically the politically
favored few inflation also distorts the
price signals propagated by fiat
currency which causes entrepreneurs to
over borrow miss allocate capital and
miss price risk and this is very
pathological to an economy really and so
we think of inflation it's kind of like
I say like it's like a computer virus
almost it corrupts these data packets on
value and scarcity that we call price
signals and for the same reason same
economic principles and reasons that
price-fixing led to the starvation of
millions in Soviet Russia fixing the
price of money which is the interest
rate causes these recurrent economic
calamities while we today call the
business cycle and we think again is
normal but it's not it's a consequence
of centrally planned money and a key
piece of this is not only that it
happens but the lack of information and
transparency in education
of those that are at the bottom of that
pyramid scheme that you described who
don't understand it's happening and
don't have the information necessary to
to measure what is happening right I
always go back to this idea of tell me
how much money was printed today exactly
you can now there's ways to triangulate
right there's a smartass who says you
know I can tell you what the bank asset
balance sheet okay I get it
but how many people understand that the
dollar in their wallet actually is worth
less money today than it was last year
yeah if you go out on the street I'm
willing to bet 50 plus percent of the
330 million Americans have no clue that
concept is so foreign to they have no
clue right and so what ends up happening
is there's an education advantage or an
information advantage that some portion
of the population has over others but
even those that know this happens they
don't know how bad it is yes right and I
think that's where you start to unpack
some of this and realize wait a minute
how what is the solution yeah I another
thing interesting aspect of that is you
know again we know anyone everyone knows
how much Bitcoin was produced today and
every day forever how many people these
this army of macro economists and
analysts and CNBC people there that pour
over the details of Central Bank
meetings they're their body language
their wardrobes trying to figure out
what they're going to do next like it's
such a total drain of human ingenuity
and and capability it's just it's really
silly I think when you see it that way
I'm trying to quickly look up and I may
not be able to find it quick enough I
believe it is the Federal Reserve's GDP
forecast
shout out to to mark usko he's the one
who who told me this one I think that
they have now made something like 220
right so somewhere around the number of
forecasts what percentage of the time
have they been right sub 5% zero zero
they've gone zero for 220 or whatever
yeah now again I believe that to be
correct people
we'll fact-check me online but if I
remember the information correctly it's
zero if it's not zero it's a very very
small number less than 5% and so when
that happens you have this centrally
planned model but the people who are
doing the planning aren't accurately
forecasting what is going to happen a
hundred because it's not a possible is
it's kind of decisions exactly well it's
just hard to make decisions that it's
impossible an economy is a complex
adaptive system like the weather right
you cannot control or manage an economy
any more than you can manage the [ __ ]
weather frankly we got a president who
thinks he's going he's got a new Couric
ain't it yeah we won't go there go ahead
that's how you know out of control
things have gotten right so as with all
well-functioning markets the price of
money must emerge through and constantly
reorient itself against the natural
interactions of supply and demand
attempts to centrally plan this market
only distort truth in the form of
distorted price signals and trigger over
borrowing recessions and caused the boom
and bust business cycle so on another
way to look at fiat currency price
signal distortion is with Witten Stein's
ruler there's another thing I got from
to lub this is really interesting to
think about unless you have confidence
in a rulers reliability if you use a
ruler to measure a table you may also be
using the table to measure the ruler god
that's good the less you trust the
rulers reliability the more information
you are getting about the ruler and less
about the table right so said
differently the more you can trust the
constancy of a unit of measurement the
more signal it gives you in the less is
you that is so good I've never heard
that before that is so good so back to
Bitcoin with an absolutely fixed supply
Bitcoin will restore the clarity of
these economic price signals that are so
critical to proper capital allocation
risk assessment and entrepreneurial
coordination across space-time so kind
of simply free market money like gold
was a universal system of measurement
everyone could trust it everyone could
trust it and it was constant and
reliable anywhere in the world right so
other universal units of measurement
like
seconds meters or kilograms they're all
immutable in value to maximize the
coordination of human action upon these
foundations of standardized measurement
or the machinery of global commerce is
constructed builders of skyscrapers
electronics and all other goods rely on
the constancy of these measurements of
these measurement units when sourcing
materials and coordinating labour
efforts from around the world the
immutable money supply of Bitcoin means
that once it is used widely enough to
function as a unit of account that it's
price signals will carry more truth than
any other money in history bitcoin is a
monetary channel free from the noise of
unexpected supply fluctuations which
necessarily means it carries the
clearest signals in this way bitcoin is
the perfect conveyor of the data packets
on value and scarcity known as price
signals so I like to say the analogy I
share as I say money's like economic
water and when it comes to price signals
fiat currency is inscrutably murky it's
got lots of noise you can't tell whether
a price change is real or its inflation
driven right bitcoin is the opposite it
is crystal clear it is pure signal and
has absolutely zero unexpected inflation
forever so an economy run on a Bitcoin
standard would have fewer and less
extreme booms and bust and the Bitcoin
standard by the way as a book that
everyone needs to reading safety give us
give us our cut of books el faro that
the Bitcoin standard is a fantastic book
safe teen wrote it and you should
definitely
so yeah bitcoin is basically the most
truthful money that's okay so I just
wrote down this question but now's a
good time to ask it if you hold the
assumption that bitcoin is going to be
the most provable true unit of
measurement write it like seconds meters
etc will not change it has that
consistency why do so many intelligent
people fear truth meaning there's a lot
of really really smart people who have
done various levels of work on Bitcoin
most of them kind of surface-level drive
by knowledge what I call it and they yet
do not believe that it has value or do
not believe that it will be valuable in
the future how do we kind of figure out
that contrast between these are very
smart intelligent people who actually
seek truth in most aspects of their life
especially their investing or
entrepreneurial careers yet when it
comes to something that is provably true
there's a disconnect yeah you're really
digging into the seismic nests that's
been a word of this shift like it truly
is a once--in
I when you and I think melt dim talked
about the transition to double entry
bookkeeping and Bitcoin being this
transition to triple entry bookkeeping I
think it's really hard for people to
comprehend the magnitude of black swans
like this and black swans don't
necessarily doesn't mean something's
negative per se it's just something
that's very hard to predict that has a
huge impact the Internet's a Black Swan
event if you're a great internet looking
and saying we did through this computer
network what is yes and that is the best
analogy for Bitcoin but you know Bitcoin
really kind of is the Internet in a lot
of ways it's just where the Internet is
this open source free market set of
protocols for moving information Bitcoin
is the same thing for moving value so as
far as smart people not grasping it I
really think because Bitcoin takes a lot
of hours to dig into and have the
lightbulb moment I think a lot of people
just haven't done the work and I that
number I think varies between people but
it's high alright it's between one and
two three hundred hours probably of just
studying Bitcoin and all this multi
multi disciplinary domain to really
grasp the significance of it all right
the next principle yes full of radical
transparency yes so the protocol
principle of radical transparency ray
describes as quote by radical
transparency I mean giving most everyone
the ability to see most everything on
so in free-market capitalism we have
three cornerstones which we mentioned
earlier we have rule of law which gives
us a means of nonviolent dispute
resolution we have private property
rights which gives us respect for the
relationships between people and assets
and we have hard money which gives us a
free market selected money and an
accurate conveyor of price signals so
with strong and reliable rules in place
entrepreneurs are then free to play the
game so to speak accumulating capital
for themselves and diffusing any
innovations gleaned in the process into
the whole of society through trade so an
analogy here is like if you imagine a
poker player sitting at a table or if
and if the hand rankings changed every
few hands at the whims of the casino
without sound rules on which to build a
strategy no player would remain engaged
for long and they would quickly exit the
game so we have kind of a similar
problem today with centrally planned
money the problem with the perceived
safety of the u.s. dollar is the opacity
of the rules which govern its existence
including how many dollars are there in
existence as US earlier how many will be
issued in the years to come who gets to
decide or are there criteria for
deciding and most importantly who stands
to profit from their production right so
even though the US dollar today is
really just an SQL database maintained
at the Federal Reserve they could choose
to open its records to audit they refuse
right to counterbalance its opacity and
we touched a little bit on this earlier
there's an army of macro economist
analysts and market commentators poring
over ever every detail of the statements
issued by central bankers including not
only their words their tone delivery and
even their wardrobes it's it's
incredible it's unbelievable
did they say dovish yes what's her tie
yellow so to understand how absurd this
is imagine if a semi governmental agency
was put in charge of setting prices for
automobiles ask any free-market
capitalist if this seems like a good
idea and he will spew vitriol at you for
even suggesting such a socialistic
method of managing prices for
automobiles
any true capitalist will tell you that
only the market should determine prices
at the intersection of supply and demand
but then very smoothly point out to them
that the Fed sets the pricing of the US
dollar which is the interest rate which
is the United States most valuable
export market and does so based on
undisclosed criteria in closed door
discussions indeed fiat currency is
antithetical to free-market capitalism
it is monetary socialism explained very
quickly the interest rate and how that
is the pricing of the US dollar and this
idea that it's the most valuable export
market yeah so essentially there with
money you have the supply of loanable
funds if you will which would be the
money supply you have demand for loans
and wherever supply and demand crosses
is the price which is the interest rate
and that's just the interest rate you
see on loans but the Fed sets this price
like as if the Fed came out and said all
cars or $20,000 are all 25,000 and as we
know from you know studying Soviet
Russia and whatever every time you try
to interfere with free market dynamics
you create surpluses or shortages it
just causes damage to the economy the
market has to clear at the price the
market clears at and this is where you
see the current President President
Trump
absolutely railing on the federal
reserve publicly via tweets etc saying
hey other economies are doing X or Y yes
we're not they have an advantage we
don't except some of that is he doesn't
have control right his uh you know kind
of executive branches never control to
the opacity of the rules and criteria
etcetera but also the optimization for
different things right one of the one of
the things that I forget I really wish I
could remember who said this cuz I
thought it was just incredibly you know
clear in the way they described it they
said central bank's job is not to manage
money the central bank's job is to
manage economies of which money is a
tool to do and I thought that it was
very interesting because again
take the president take an entrepreneur
take an investor take the Federal
Reserve all four of those people exist
in one single economy they all may be
optimizing for different things and
therefore want different things in a
free market the market is the ultimate
referee this in this world that's not
the case
absolutely yeah it's you know the
Federal Reserve is central banking in
general is intended to be politically
agnostic right the presidents will have
no say in it but you can just see you
put people in charge of something it
becomes politicized it's inevitable yeah
and Trump's is taking it to the ultimate
extreme where he's tweeting directly out
these guys let's tweet the other day
who's the worst enemy for the US you
know the Chinese President or Jerome
Powell
oh he say something like that world are
we living in so it's hard man is crazy
it's truly crazy so I like to say that
in markets sunlight is the best
disinfectant when everyone can see the
criteria and process behind a decision
they are more likely to deem it
trustworthy with Bitcoin the algorithm
which sets its money supply is totally
transparent meaning people can
universally agree that the system is
fair and unbiased as an open source
monetary protocol Bitcoin is essentially
the principle of radical transparency in
perpetual action and bankers hate this
because Bitcoin basically automates the
functions of a central bank which are
maintaining money supplies or monetary
policy reaching consensus as to account
balances and facilitating international
value flows this transparency and money
also gives us the restoration of strong
property rights and money few people
realize that monetary inflation is a
direct violation of property rights
crazily this is a legally enforced
injustice right we're talking about the
cornerstone of capitalism that's legally
enforced that we're breaking it's it's
legalized counterfeiting as what
inflation is printing money is like
amending the list of who owns what since
money can be used to obtain anything in
the market and a corruption of the
private property rights intrinsic to
capitalism itself so Bitcoin as an
answer to this is an uninflated
confiscation resistant free market based
money
this provides its users with stronger
property rights than inflatable
confiscated and deauthorize Abal fiat
currencies so in this sense bitcoin is
the purely transparent alternative to
the opacity of central banking it is a
beacon of light out competing an
industry purposefully shrouded in
darkness once properly understood
bitcoins superior visibility and escape
ibly enhances its believability explain
that so bitcoins superior visibility
inescapably enhances its believability
it is an immutable unbreakable rule set
whereas the rules and fiat currency and
central banking are shifting all the
time based on political agendas and
twists and turns sweet coin is the
ultimate meritocracy because it can
withstand any attack exactly whereas the
existing system is based on who says it
when just say it where they say it how
this subject of political capture it's
not the merit of the idea that wins
exactly so as and once you see that you
know again once you have that light bulb
moment with Bitcoin you can't unsee it I
think clearly you've seen it it's like
it is it's it's an epiphany I don't know
what else to call it really and as
you've said ray quote having nothing to
hide relieves stress and builds trust
unquote
transparency and reliability are the
essence of bitcoins utility as money so
how do you not believe in Bitcoin and
it's truly unique in that its supply is
absolutely predictable and absolutely
scarce so in this sense Bitcoin is the
most credible monetary policy in human
history now competing the least
trustworthy monetary policies in human
history so I recently have started to
talk about this much more publicly which
is going back to your point earlier
about why can't a new black one get
created everyone always thinks and talks
about this from a technology standpoint
well Fiats are all gonna get digitized
right you know other people can create
digital currencies true on a technology
competition kind of horizontal playing
field
everything is going to be digital
whether it is Bitcoin whether there's a
fiat currency a new digital currency etc
but that's not where the competition
ends up right it's like saying hey there
you should be Internet companies versus
non internet companies now they're all
internet colors right the competition is
at the monetary policy lots of and what
you said here is Bitcoin is the most
credible monetary policy in history out
competing the least trustworthy monetary
policies in history this from a monetary
policy competition standpoint this is a
landslide you know in terms of which one
is more transparent which one is more
believable and which one is more
predictable know if those three things
end up being important I think we know
who the winner ends up being if those
three things for some reason end up not
being important then other currencies
have a choice I think you and I are in
the camp of those three things are
pretty damn important a quick study of
history we have been and in theory
always would be important right so long
as people seek to store their wealth
across time so as long as human
self-interest is a thing this scarce as
money wins right that's what gold is and
now that's what bitcoin is so bitcoins
rapidly gaining a track record superior
to central banks across all dimensions
reliability predictability auditability
cost-effectiveness and resistance to
censorship or manipulation it is thereby
further eroding the believability of
central bankers which is in shorter
supply with every dollar printed which
brings us to the third formulaic element
of Ray's idea meritocracy the principle
of believability weighted
decision-making I don't even know what
that is
yeah this is a this one's a mouthful so
ray describes it as quote when you're
responsible for a decision compare the
believability weighted decision-making
of the crowd to what you believe unquote
so the believability weighted
decision-making okay yep so
if we look at fiat currency in terms of
believability the best-performing
central bank fiat currency in history as
we mentioned earlier was a British pound
as lost ninety nine and a half percent
of its value in three hundred and
seventeen years and when it comes to
maintaining purchasing power across time
gold has a believable track record norse
fiat currencies could barely be less
believable an ounce of gold this is a
popular one an ounce of gold is roughly
equaled the value of fine man's suit for
over a century whereas the cost of the
same student dollars has skyrocketed
further the implementation of fiat
currency offers limited to no assurances
to its users that their wealth will be
protected from confiscation censorship
inflation or counterfeit and even if you
believe in central banking flat out and
you're just committed to it you would
still be really hard-pressed to defend
the believability of central bankers
themselves not only for their missed
forecast as you alluded to earlier but a
number of other things so as Ray says
quote think about people's believability
which is a function of their
capabilities and their willingness to
say what they think keep their track
records in mind unquote in terms of
capabilities central bankers have
irrigated themselves virtually unlimited
latitude to manipulate the supply and
price of fiat currency in pursuit of
politically determined ends they have
exercised these privileges based on
largely undisclosed criteria and are
notorious for their veiled communication
styles in other words central bankers
seem quite unwilling to say what they
think and their decision-making criteria
are shrouded in falsehood and in regards
to track records central bankers likely
hold the wor the world record for the
most abysmal performance in history
they've caused multiple waves of
currency devaluation and unemployment
during their reign over money over about
the past century and since reputation
must be earned through honesty it is
unsurprising that central banks have
struggled in this respect as their
business model is built on deception so
one thing that I'm going to say here
which I think is an important thing
and I thought a lot about earlier you
were talking about central bankers seem
quite unwilling to say what they think
some of that is because it is personally
valuable or from a central banking same
place valuable for them not to say what
they think right the other part is the
words they use are important because
people nitpick over every single word so
it's almost like you have this
self-fulfilling prophecy of I'm gonna be
careful what I say because that's what's
good for central banks for dollar
dominance etc and then oh by the way now
you're gonna be super nitpicky so then I
really can't say what I mean and you
know it kind of just reinforces stuff
over and over and over again
and somebody once said to me they were
like Jerome pausing at the hardest job
in the world because literally if he
says one wrong word you know all kinds
of chaos can't win and so I'm actually
of the belief that the job is near
impossible right it's incredibly
difficult at predicting GDP and all the
sudden is just super super difficult and
so the individual people are really just
trying to do their job right yes now
from a systemic macro standpoint huge
issues it's no one single person who is
responsible for that right it's overtime
it's a lot of people different
organizations etc but separating the
people from the structure I think it's
really important and it's very similar
to like a lot of people go to work and
just want to do their job I think most
of them actually think they're doing
what they're supposed to be doing I
think you and I are talked about the
macro system here which is very very
flawed over a long period of time
absolutely I mean the system for by
virtually every measurement does not
work and the job is impossible because
trying to hold back free market dynamics
is like trying to hold back the tide
right these things they play out their
natural organizing principles their
intrinsic to nature you can't fight
mother nature so I think we're just you
know we saw Soviet Russia collapse when
they tried to centrally plan everything
in the economy we have competed them
because we gave free market rein to
everything except money but now we're
just going to see central control over
money fall for sure for the same reasons
so another way to look at the
the ability of money is by setting facts
versus opinions opinions are like soft
money and that they can easily be
diluted and distorted which is very
clear in politics for instance facts
though are like hard money and that they
are rooted in scientific realities in
the case of gold
these are chemistry and physical rarity
and in the case of Bitcoin these are
mathematics and thermodynamics so said
simply do we believe the largest market
in the world is best governed by opinion
or fact and again this comes back to my
question why do so many intelligent
people fear facts fear Jeff yeah keep
going yeah it's crazy so in this respect
I could say buying bitcoin is like
behind a put option on central banker
malfeasance or going long facts and
short opinions which is kind of like
your long Bitcoin short the bankers I
guess said differently long facts in
short of pains is probably a more
popular way one Bitcoin short the banks
so the reason central bankers cannot be
believed is because they lack skin in
the game
Taleb sums us up sums up skin in the
game nicely by saying quote don't tell
me what you think just show me what's in
your portfolio unquote and regardless of
what they say or think central bankers
have been stuffing their portfolios with
gold lately and that that is the
indication of of gold as dominant
free-market money so money which is the
largest and most critical market in the
world simply cannot evolve without
practitioners who are subjected to
real-world consequences and trade-offs
in real time since central bankers don't
face the consequences of their decisions
they suffer from the agency problem
which is a conflict of interest inherent
to any organization where one party is
expected to act on another party's best
interest but is not exposed to the
proper balance of incentives and
disincentives to do so so said simply if
you lack skin in the game then you lack
believability right and just real quick
I just quickly googled central bank gold
buying so central bank's accumulated
over 668 ton
in gold purchases this year which is
more than 2018 s record numbers so 18
set a record 19 surpassed it in fact the
key drivers in gold demand this year
stemmed from central bank purchases most
of which were bought 390 tons
during the first two quarters of 2019
and so the central bank gold purchases
in 2019 surpassed last year's 50-year
high exactly and so over the last 50
years central banks have never held more
gold or menthe more gold going back to
your believability
that all came from Bitcoin comm and we
you know the corollary is we've never
printed this much money right so they're
literally hedging against one another's
counterparty risk holding each other's
currency which again going back to
individuals versus the macro system if
you're an individual sitting in that
seat you know you're printing a lot of
money and also there's a hedge out there
the rational thing is to buy a bunch of
gold while you print absol right so
they're doing what is rational from
their seat yes we're talking about
here's the more macro structure is
flawed and that's why they're having to
do it and I would say to make good
economic decisions you could completely
ignore everything they say and just
watch that pattern yet alone so the skin
in the game
explains why ancient Roman architects
were required to required by law to
stand beneath their monolithic arches
when the scaffolding was removed often
with their families I love that so this
this deadly disincentive to mal
performance worked wonders as some of
the oldest arches constructed in this
way are still standing at over 2,000
years of age so what if central bankers
were subjected to the devastation they
inflict on economies should their
decision-making not work out perhaps the
world would be still be on a gold
standard and the the dire need for
Bitcoin today would be drastically
lessened so without skin in the game
your interests are inherently conflicted
and you suffer from an agency problem
anytime you're managing other people's
money and this includes central bankers
and this is why most asset allocators
prefer to invest in hedge fund managers
that have a substantial amounts of their
own net worth tied up in their funds
because that is skin in the game right
and it's also why central planning
always causes moral hazard because the
overlords are not exposed to the
gravity they inflict on their people so
an important piece here is part of
inflation that rarely gets talked about
is that inflation actually causes wealth
inequality yes and the reason this
occurs is that as we print more money
the currency it's also dollars become
less and less valuable right just
inflation is devaluing the dollar but
the quote-unquote wealthy the elite the
rich the the top really 25 to 50 percent
of individuals they don't keep 100
percent of their wealth in the currency
they keep it in real assets and so if
the currency is being devalued away the
asset prices actually Rises so what we
get is we get this very specific
separation in a population so take the
United States for example at least the
bottom 50% if not more
cannot afford a four to five hundred
dollar emergency payment though so what
that means is they live their life
paycheck to paycheck with near 100% if
not a hundred percent of their wealth in
cash though and every year that is being
worth less and less this is the feeling
of I can't get ahead I can't get ahead I
can't get ahead so inflation is eating
away at their wealth the remainder of
the population whether that's 30 40 50
you know 50 percent they take a portion
usually a majority portion of their
wealth and they do not leave it in cash
they buy stocks they buy real estate
they buy all kinds of different assets
or you know all stop as the dollar is
deflate a devalued away you then get
asset price rising so you're getting the
quote-unquote poor or the people in cash
are getting poorer
and the quote-unquote wealthy those
within real assets are actually getting
richer the rich get richer the poor get
poorer and this is exactly what you're
talking about here is not only is this
centrally planned model they don't have
quote-unquote skin in the game from a
well if you make bad decisions but on
top of that their own personal wealth is
protected from
this inflation and devaluation because
they actually own real assets they don't
hold cash that's right
that is why we're getting the wealth
inequality guess we have and if we can
remove that structural issue all of a
sudden we have a much more fair equal
world yes there's a lot of people don't
want to see that happen absolutely I
think one of the biggest consequences of
that is you see real-estate prices
soaring right it always goes up doesn't
it this is residential this is corporate
real estate it's everything and this has
a really perverse effect because I would
argue that people sort of near the top
or in the middle put a lot of their
wealth in their house right and because
they're trying to protect it from
inflation right it's there's ernesta
gets their savings tool this has a
perverse consequence of causing the
market prices of homes to go to create a
bubble and actually drives homelessness
so consequences if you look at the money
supply increase from 2008 to today and
the increase in the homeless population
in this country they're very highly
correlated and I would argue that that's
why all right you're pricing people out
of homes and if you overlay that same
chart with wealth and equality charts
somehow it looks very similar and the
S&P 500 right looks very similar and and
part of this too is I what I find
especially when it comes to Bitcoin you
know you and I talked a lot of different
types of people and they're all kind of
trying to figure it out
when I get behind closed doors with
intelligent people in the finance
industry they all know this happens no
it's not fun to talk about
it's not in favor to talk about it's not
it doesn't make it easier to go to sleep
at night etc but it is important to talk
about
oops and the more that we talk about it
the more awareness that restores it and
I think that awareness drives the the
desire to fix this right and so if
people don't talk about it I don't care
how uncomfortable it is you can't fix
the problem it goes back to the idea of
transparency and truth absolutely again
everything starts out as an idea right
shock and
it's almost like da Leo's on to
something yeah and I forget who said it
but someone said there's nothing in the
world that can stop an idea whose time
has come it's true and it feels like
Bitcoin Stein was calm so we're gonna
get into that all right yeah so talking
about skin in the game
you know central banks have none
essentially and on the other hand all
market participants in Bitcoin have skin
in the game the note operators are
incentivized to maintain the rules
miners are incentivized to sanctify the
Bitcoin Ledger efficiently developers
expend their time supporting an open
source project Bitcoin holder's expend
real resources to acquire their Bitcoin
all of these Bitcoin market participants
are just like the ancient Roman
architects standing beneath our newly
unscaled at arches they all have skin in
the game that's what makes the system
work there's a lot of bitcoiners you
just got super excited when you describe
Roman architects standing beneath the
unscaled arches alright go ahead
so to pull it all back together
going back to Ray's formula that we
outline or the Ray gives us for the idea
of meritocracy and it's free market
equivalent we have the idea meritocracy
equals radical truth plus radical
transparency plus believability weighted
decision-making which is equivalent to
the free market format of free markets
equal truthful price signals transparent
and reliable rule of law private
property rights and hard money plus skin
in the game weighted decision-making
based on what we have learned so far we
can translate these equations once again
into central banking and Bitcoin
versions where we have central banking
equals untruthful price signals because
they broke the honesty of money there
there is still transparent and reliable
rule of law because central banking
doesn't really affect the rule of laws
so much but they have marginalized
private property rights because they
confiscate people's wealth via inflation
and there they have soft money right it
is not free market determined and it's
used as a mechanism of control and they
have the agency problem weighted
decision-making they don't have skin in
the game so they have an agency problem
instead so central banking equals
untruthful price signals
Plus transparent reliable rule of law
marginalized private property rights and
soft money plus agency problem weighted
decision-making yes how's that compare
to Bitcoin and so Bitcoin on the other
hand has absolutely truthful price
signals this is something that is even
it's even more scarce than gold right
gold is relatively scarce bitcoin is
absolutely scarce which makes it the
perfect medium to move price signals
through essentially it also has
transparent and reliable rule of law it
has private property rights which are
restored in Bitcoin because it's
uninflated all you can't steal people's
Bitcoin via inflation or confiscation
and it is an absolutely hard money
meaning that it's free market determined
and it can't be inflated at all plus it
has skin in the game weighted this
decision making as we just covered with
its market participants so in this sense
clearly bitcoin is 100% consistent with
the equation for free markets
whereas central banking is almost
entirely inconsistent since this free
market equation is equivalent to the
idea meritocratic equation we may deduce
bitcoin is completely consistent with
Ray's formulation of the idea
meritocracy and central banking is not
so if we go all the way back to the
beginning to raise original assessment
of Bitcoin assuming raised principles
are stated forthrightly how can he
possibly be a non-believer in Bitcoin
bitcoin is both an idea meritocracy and
a free market and as you said ray quote
when someone says I believe X ask them
what data are you looking at
what reasoning are using to draw your
conclusion unquote so let me ask you Ray
after bitcoins impeccable performance
for over a decade it's had over ninety
nine point nine eight percent uptime
it's never been hacked its evolved into
the most secure computing network in the
world it's storing around 200 billion in
market value depending on the day and it
has cleared over one trillion dollars of
USD value of transactions in total what
data and reasoning are you using to draw
your conclusion about Bitcoin ray my
guess is it like many smart people you
have disregarded Bitcoin at the outset
in accordance with one of your favor
principles I implore you to keep an open
mind about Bitcoin and perhaps you'll
come to see it as an embodiment of
open-minded open-mindedness itself so
let's stop there we've probably got
another 15 or 20 minutes and I want to
talk about a couple of things the first
is I'm not gonna compare Ray Dalio and
Warren Buffett they're two very separate
types of people I think very separate
thought processes etc I'm in the camp
when it comes to Warren Buffett of let's
not ask the person who openly states hey
I'm not a technologist I don't really
understand technology stuff I'm usually
a little bit later than most they're
probably at the best person dad would
have his portfolio's banks of course
write the whole thing that's you know I
think most people understand that they
listen to me raise different is it
important for ready to believe in
Bitcoin for aid to publicly come out in
the state that he sees value in it or is
he in the camp with many others where it
doesn't really matter Bitcoin doesn't
care I would say it doesn't matter what
any of us individually think at all
what's up to the market to decide right
markets like mark a little referee
that's right markets are free market is
selecting Bitcoin currently but I do
think because of the the violation of
civil liberties that central banking
represents that it would be encouraging
to see a thought leader someone of race
stature and the space to come out and
speak positively about Bitcoin I think
that would just be a good humanitarian
effort if you will but it doesn't matter
if the market will decide the Keene and
so you've done a fantastic job of laying
out what I'll called the structural
reasons of not only one why the existing
system has flaws and likely those flaws
can be accelerated or exasperated to
ultimate failure you've also laid out
this argument for why structurally
Bitcoin is a solution if not the
solution
how it can very quickly continue to
double and triple down on its benefits
and ultimately kind of have this
ascension or rise in the world where do
we go
right and what I mean by that is can
Bitcoin become the next global reserve
currency can Bitcoin be used as a unit
of account will it just how do you think
about where we sit today in 2020 and
kind of what happens over the next 10 to
20 years so there's an excellent book
that's very popular goals called the
sovereign individual this book was
written in the mid 90s I believe and it
was very prescient in the sense that it
predicted it predicted anonymous cyber
cash ie Bitcoin it predicted the
digitization of securities which we I
think is next and the thesis of this
book is that society comes to reflect
the technology on which it is built so
in the industrial
giant you know huge industrial complexes
basically to move the earth and build
the buildings and all the things so we
developed around that a gigantic
nation-state and the argument is that
now that society is being facilitated by
the microprocessor and digital
technology that will actually shrink the
role of government and we'll see a
dramatic decentralization of government
over the coming years and so I think
we're moving into a world where the role
of government and the nation-state and
our lives as kind of this oppressive
institution is going to be declining
gradually and then you know suddenly at
some point and it's really hard to see
past that this thing you know the
nation-state model is so fundamental to
our identity all right we all I'm an
American I'm this I'm that it's but at
the end of the day we're all just people
on the planet so I think it's as much of
a cultural epiphany as it is a financial
innovation as it is almost a religious
change it's really it's really profound
as that occurs governments central banks
others kind of those in power they're
not going to just say Oh
show's over shut the lights closed let's
go home let's let's go take our bow said
then we're gonna go home right we're
seeing some steps that we've seen before
right so in past recessionary periods
the two things that we've seen happen or
on average we see interest rate cuts of
about 500 basis points or more
and then we see quantitative easing or
the printing of more capital the
interest rate cuts we've seen a little
bit happening obviously where we said
today we don't have 500 basis points to
cut so it where's the likelihood we're
going to zero or if not negative there
are some areas in the world where we've
got negative already - is the printing
of cash in the United States you know
there's a whole bunch of controversy
should we do it now should it you know
happen later whatever but one of the
things that recently came out is a Hong
Kong so they're dealing with two
specific issues right now they've got
the protests kind of the anti Beijing or
anti China conversation a lot of
was very peaceful and at times has
become violent and then got back from
he's full and kind of balancing back and
forth protest and then they've got the
coronavirus kind of this you know
virology related thing that really to me
the coronavirus is less about the virus
is gonna go kill millions of people and
it's more about creating fear which
leads to economic slowdown yep right and
so if you get protests which obviously
shut down cities etc you get economic
slowdown you kind of exasperate that
with the virus so don't they've
introduced a fifteen billion dollar
economic stimulus plan recently and as
part of that plan they are going to give
10,000 Hong Kong dollars which is the
equivalent about 1,200 bucks u.s. to
seven plus million citizens helicopter
money so we're seeing it in action yeah
it used to be we would print the money
and go buy assets to inject the money
into the financial system
I saw multiple articles from what many
would consider legitimate truthful
mainstream media organizations so some
would say that's an oxymoron some would
not but these are these are well
respected publications and and things
that I read on a daily basis and we're
in phrases give away used and as I sat
there and I thought about this all I
could say to myself was you don't give
away something that has value right I've
never done that in my life
because even philanthropic etc you get
back whether its moral yes rewards will
you get back
intellectual rewards right you get back
kind of you're in a better mood like I'm
like there's always some I give
something I get something in our term
helicopter money is coming and the
reason I want to talk to you about this
is Ray Dalio has pretty much said we've
got modern monetary theory which is
essentially helicopter money though
whether you think it's good or not it is
on the horizon and we're kind of
speeding towards that yes what is that
world look like so I guess a couple of
things and I believe the figures are by
the Year 2022 the US government will be
generating tax revenue below its
interest expense so if you can imagine
trying to if you may so we're like a
unit economic negative if you made a
hundred thousand dollars a year but you
paid a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars of year of interest on your
credit cards you can only imagine what
direction you're going as far as
widening loss you're going to bankruptcy
like that's it's mathematically certain
when it's not gonna happen
I think it's 2022 when oh this is like
two years a couple of years yeah and
that's so let's say people are bad at
math it happens in 2025 yes so you've
got it going that direction and then I
would say that and that's all the while
tearing society apart at the center
right driving this wealth disparity so
you have this buildup of populism this
potential of social revolt you know
people are on the streets they're mad
we've seen this all over the world and
you really saw it after 2008 the Occupy
Wall Street movement and it's almost
like the fiscal and monetary policy
tools just get more and more creative to
try and fight those fires and I think
helicopter money is probably just the
last expression of that just really
trying to give people money to make ends
meet but at the same time you're driving
hyperinflation of said money in the in
the near term by printing that much
money right so it's it better to give it
to the people rather than to buy assets
I guess in the short run perhaps but it
at the end of the day when you're
printing this much money value flows to
scarcity right so we're talking about
realist
businesses gold and you know the
scarcest liquid asset in human history
absolutely scarce Bitcoin so I think you
just have to watch the actions of
central bank's again they're buying gold
and then protect yourself with owning
real things not storing your value in
currency but in any case it ends a it's
ugly the end is ugly right it's
literally tearing apart the trust fabric
the whole society together and it's
painful for for everyone what's your
biggest fear over the next decade when
it comes to the relationship between
Bitcoin central plain planned money and
I'll just call it the economy in general
the financial system you know I guess a
lot of this has to do with how quickly
it happens there's actually if hyper
Bitcoin is Asian which is a term where
Bitcoin becomes the dominant world
reserve money a lot of people use if
that happened today I actually think it
would increase the wealth disparity a
lot
why because bitcoins not widely
penetrated in the world right make less
than 1% of the world hold it so if it
happened today
you'd have 1% all of a sudden holding
the most valuable asset in the world and
99% excluded so I think if hyper Bitcoin
ization happens too fast in the short
run it could maybe exacerbate the
problems now in the long run it's
clearly better for all the reasons we
outlined today but the transition is
just hard to predict the timing of and
you know transitions are inherently
bloody so I guess it's earning
one of our last questions for you is we
talked a lot about this
centrally-planned money and economies is
it bad like having a centrally planned
economy and money to some degree
instills order right the free market can
create chaos it can create volatility
price discovery all stuff is it all bad
or is it just macro level long term not
good how do you think about that so to
love would say you can suppress the
volatility inherent to nature in the
short run which central banks are
designed to do right price stability
target unemployment etc but all you're
doing
ultimately is delaying the nonlinear
outcomes of this volatility into the
future and making it worse you're
amplifying it so I think any time you
try to impose a regulation or central
planning body on a free market system
you're you may be better and that medium
term that the system operates and
functions well as it has for some time
now but the ending gets worse and worse
so if we're keeping the ends in mind
know the free market is the ideal
organizing principle for Humanity what's
the best book you've ever read you know
a long time ago I read a book called the
Dow of the way off the beaten path but
for me when I was a kid I was a very
scientifically minded kid and didn't
have much of a respect for the spiritual
domain but this book bridged the to for
me it drew I think the taught the
subtitle of the book is the parallels
between ancient Eastern mysticism and
quantum physics and that book is
incredible it's written 2530 years ago
but it just made me a more whole person
I guess
what's the story behind the tattoo I
have a Bitcoin tattoo you on the inside
of my right arm and I got this it is the
Bitcoin symbol with the circle it is the
Bitcoin symbol
oh he just flexed he flexed watch out
get the police he just flexed he
literally just flex his bicep I was